Ukrainian soldiers waved their flag at
the entrance to Lee man
[Music]
footage that Al Jazeera cannot
independently verify shows dead soldiers
and burnt out tanks beside the road
the Ukrainian military said it
surrounded the strategically important
town in the partially Russian occupied
region of Donetsk hours later the
Russian military said it had been forced
to retreat
there was a high risk of being encircled
so our forces were withdrawn from the
position in liman to more advantageous
lines
pro-russia media Ed video believed to
show a Russian tank retreating north
towards cremina a town Russian forces
still control
we tried to save our strength and
control the road between liman and the
town crimina there are reinforcements
trying to get in and establish positions
in order to stop the ukrainians
Ukrainian forces celebrated pushing
Russian forces out of one of a number of
villages in the surrounding area
Ukrainian soldiers and volunteers
evacuated more civilians from the
Frontline town of Bahamut that has come
under increasing Russian shelling in
recent weeks
because of the secondary shelling you
see what happened yesterday or the day
before yesterday a projectile fell there
was an older man in the house they took
him away I was in the kitchen when the
explosion happened here it is impossible
to be here
Ukrainian authorities say more than half
the 70 000 people who lived in bahmoud
and the surrounding area before the war
have already fled
if the Ukrainian army take full control
of Lee man and the surrounding Villages
it will be a huge military and strategic
victory for them it's believed from
there they will try to push both
Northeast and Southeast towards
russian-occupied areas of Lufkin Donetsk
the Russians say this retreat was
strategic
before Kiev and its NATO Partners it
will be seen as a humiliating defeat
Charles Stratford Al Jazeera crematorsk